こんにちは。はじめしゃちょーです。（ドヤ）
みなさん！YouTuberいろいろたくさん人がいると思うんですけども～
誰しもがYouTuberやってると思うんですけども～
みんな編集というものをしています。
で、僕もよくあるんですけど編集の中でミスをします。
僕は特にします。
まあYouTubeの中にはいろんなYouTuberの動画があるんですけども～
その中でも数々のミスがある。
で たぶんこの動画はひょっとしたら
YouTubeみてるみなさんのほうが
気づくかもしんないし
Youtuberやってるひともあぁ～～～～そういうのあるやん
みたいなかんじで共感を得ることがでこきるかもしれないんですけども
今回ですねその
YouTuber編集の中である編集ミスあるあるというものを
ちょっと僕の経験および
ほかのYoutuberの動画をみてて思った
あ～この編集ミスよくあるなみたいなやつを
ちょっとまとめてみたので
あ～そういうばこういうミスもあるんだな
みたいなかんじで観てくれればうれしいです。
では行こう!!!!!
しーー
はっははははｗｗｗｗｗｗ
はああはっはっはっはっはっ！！！！！！！！！！！(大草原)
まさきの.....家の中で
ロケット花火を
あげてしまい
視聴者の皆様に迷惑をお掛けして
大変申し訳ございませんでした。
こちらのゴキブリ。
このゴキブリを
今寝てるんですけども
ターゲットの枕元において
これをおいておくとターゲットが
どんなリアクションをするのか
実際にやっていこうと思います。
あいつ虫嫌いなんでぇ～
絶対いいリアクションすると思うんでぇ～
極まりないです。(意味不明)
では。やっていきましょう！
よし！
じゃあ寝て
寝ててそこで
今ドッキリ仕掛けるから
寝てていいよ
（まさき）ここでいい？
（はじめ）うん
あの、目あけちゃだめだよ
ばれちゃう
前髪.......を
こっちに
流しつつぅ
こっち側に。こう耳にかけてすっきり
させて
今回ですね
サイコロを三つ準備して
その三つ振って
６、６、６って６が三つ出るのを１０連続
繰り返すまで寝れま１０！！！！！です。
すごい企画ですよ
これはもう!マジで楽しみ！！
では行ってみよ！！！
ハア...ハア...ハアハアハア
こんにちは
ウインナーTVです。
えぇ、今
某公園にきています。
いますね。そこに
あのおじさんがいつも公園にいるんだよ。
今回こそ絶対
絶対
あいつを
捕まえて.......。うん......。
やってやりますよ
ご当地限定のラーメンを食べていこうと思います。
あのすぐそっちの方に
おいしいラーメン屋さんがあるみたいなので
（すぅぅぅぅ）
まあ。そうですねぇ。
今日はどっちかというと味噌ラーメンとかを
食べたいなという気持ちなんで
まあ。味噌ラーメン！食べていければいいなと
思っております。
では。早速すすっていきましょう！！
んてんてんてんてんてんてんてんて
て～れれれれ～れ～てれれれ～てれれれ～れ～
てれれれ～てってれてれれれ～れ～れ～
ててっててっててててん